cheers to Downton Abbey the super
successful PBS series is coming to the
big screen if you're a fan of the show
or period pieces you must be ecstatic or
if you've never seen an episode here's
everything you need to know before you
go during its heyday from 2011 to 2016
the British series was the most-watched
PBS drama in the network's 45-year
history at its peak the show averaged 13
point 3 million viewers per week whoa
and it achieved major nominations and
wins at the Primetime Emmys and Golden
Globes for Best performances and TV
series among many other categories the
show mainly focuses on two groups the
aristocratic Crawley family and their
extended group of workers that take care
of them and their home without complain
people really love the show for its
warmth and humanity viewers felt the
characters were developed with empathy
and were performed with a beautiful
kindness the Crawley family is
privileged but the responsibilities that
come with their lifestyle were always
presented fairly the general arc of the
show is based on the Crowley's adapting
to cultural changes during the turn of
the 20th century it was clear on the way
the family and their servants were
affected by the after-effects of World
War one all of that was coupled with
changing circumstances various crimes
and unexpected joy and pain over the
years but enough of the general stuff
let's introduce you to everyone
the Crawley family is led by Robert
Crawley and as American wife Cora they
have three children Mary Edith and Sybil
and Robert's mother violet is a frequent
visitor their support staff is led by
mr. Carson the butler and mrs. Hughes
the housekeeper the group of domestic
and general estate workers change
throughout the season due to twists and
turns in the storyline okay here's a
rundown of each season boom season 1 its
1912 tragedy strikes as Lady Mary
Crawley --zz intended husband Patrick
dies seems James and Patrick
what they can't have been they weren't
going over till May and then changed
that plans that definitely on the
passenger is the crawlies are at a loss
because he was going to be the heir to
the estate but instead their distant
relative matthew becomes the next heir
both Mary and Matthew are resistant to
the aristocratic traditions of the
family which causes conflict among the
household staff new valet baits and
secretly gave footman Thomas clash
the second season begins with World War
one the Great War as they called it
still raging Mary and Matthew denying
their attraction to each other each
become engaged to other people
Sybil becomes involved with the new
chauffeur Tom and Bates is convicted of
a murder charge and sentenced to die
goatee
[Applause]
in the third season Mary and Matthew
break off their previous relationships
admit their love for one another and get
married but tragedy strikes the Crawley
family more than once leaving everyone
grieving and Tom becomes a force of
modernization on the estate
[Music]
moving further into the 1920s the fourth
season finds Mary teaming up with Tom
and running the estate edith who's
always experienced trouble with suitors
finds love and gives birth though
tragedy strikes
in 1924 the fifth season addresses anti
aristocracy feelings that are rising
more and more along with slander against
commoners this affects the Crawley
family there are state workers and
friends loyal servant Anna also becomes
a suspect in a murder and three key
characters announced huge changes in
their lives
[Music]
the sixth season sees many changes
during 1925 economic changes in Britain
affect the Crawley estate and the
household staff must be reduced
Edith takes greater charge at a magazine
she publishes Anna faces more challenges
as her relationship with Bates takes a
major turn and that wraps up the series
in the film
it looks like the estate is preparing
for major guests the king and queen are
coming to town - what hmm what calls for
this royal visit what characters would
you love to see return to Downton so now
you know and now you can go see Downton
Abbey in theatres September 20th
[Music]